[Music]
hey
everybody happy sunday what's going on i
can see your little cranberry juice yeah
it's just all cramming and getting that
damn kidney action going on
cleaning them damn kidneys jenny [ __ ]
killed me this week man it's nothing but
it wasn't me i didn't blame her [ __ ]
she said oh we got to go to this event
got to go to that event gotta go to
every time and then we gotta do the show
today was an alcoholics [ __ ] dr
this week was an alcoholics [ __ ]
dream
[Laughter]
our livers are just looking like shaking
their heads i need a break now i'm gonna
[ __ ] rest well yeah we don't have to
drink
again until friday or something right i
don't need a [ __ ] break or no
actually wednesday we have yeah we freak
out the side tracks
well honestly last night you drank like
twice as much
as i did yeah tequila because i stuck
with singles
so i only had like three or four singles
and i think you and i think you had four
or five doubles
yeah i mean you know cause lee the
bartender was like
when i when i got this that when i got
the tab he was like pointed time that
was like mostly him
yeah i was like yeah that's what i
thought because i mostly drank i drank
like
gin and tonics and then like i drank a
bunch of water in between
so i wasn't too bad yeah although i did
i did like
kind of get a little bit sick because if
i drink too much gin it's so acidic that
it kind of yeah and then we went to ihop
afterwards this is some [ __ ] so
normally
it says [ __ ] it normally like you know
when we're drunk it's like sometimes you
want mcdonald's right it's like first
they didn't do
they don't do the breakfast at night
anymore which okay
then they don't do chicken sandwiches at
night anymore yeah because there's a
mcdonald's like right
on the way home yeah on the way out so
we always used to stop there
you know just to get like a burger or
something on the way up watch [ __ ]
youtube and [ __ ]
like watch it like eating a quarter
pounder i eat like two quarter panels or
eat like two
big macs i don't even need the fries or
anything just give me two three of them
big macs
and then but i guess like we went we
tried to go there monday after memento
mori and they weren't open and i was
just kind of like whoa well
maybe they're just not like opening all
night monday but we went by there last
night which was saturday and they were
closed that too
yeah and we went around to the other one
because there's another one like kind of
up on the other
side and that one was also closed so we
went to ihop instead because yeah we're
[ __ ] open
and what was funny is that ihop of
course was a lot better
and it was basically cheaper you could
get that damn
i mean you got a lot more food for
pretty much the same amount
i had to pay tip but that's it it was
better than eating in the car
that's true and we had a cool waitress
yeah and there was a you know there was
a couple other drunk people in there but
nobody
that's a big [ __ ] place yeah they got
some nice ass bathrooms and everything
might put might put ihop at the at the
top of the list when it comes to going
home drunk
and you know what that's on the way back
from mannequins oh yeah you're right i
was going to say it's not on the way
back from downtown but it's on the way
back from mannequins
although when we go to mannequins we
usually eat at chantals because that's
like right there
we had to blow tails off a couple times
because service has been so [ __ ] up
that's true they are a little slow in
the middle
because there's not a lot of people in
there and it's just kind of like yeah
they're until four in the morning yeah
they don't really want to be working
that late they don't really care
yeah probably not because well because
like i said it's just it's usually just
us in there
and maybe like another like one other
thing like people the white
[ __ ] would go home yeah go home
i don't want to make any chicken and
waffles yeah although the chicken and
waffles are always good even at three
it's a lot more expensive at chantal's
though just that's just going to [ __ ]
ihop it's a lot faster
that breakfast was good it really it
really was i hadn't been there at like a
billion years
but uh but yeah so uh so i know that we
already talked about
mid-summer when we saw it in the theater
originally
like summer of 2019 when it came out
but i kind of feel like remember when we
first started doing the matinee show
it's just funny how much it's like
evolved over time
that we first started doing that show
because we had like the amc stubs and
like so
we were filming reviews when we were at
the theater like as soon as we came out
of the movie we would like film a review
of it like what we thought of it
and honestly i think that's kind of cool
but
i kind of like this format better
because it gives you time to
watch the movie research the movie blah
blah blah because sometimes if you just
come
out of the movie and do a review of it
on the spot
like i don't know you know like i'm
sometimes i don't know like about the
movie like so it's like oh that guy was
in it what the [ __ ] else was he in and
it's like a pain
so i don't really have time to like
research it and so i really wanted to
because um i think it was esther right
that sent us hereditary and
midsummer yeah like for your birthday
yeah and
um so we did a thing on hereditary and
then we
re-watched mid-summer on like
when like a couple nights ago yeah two
to two three nights
because i really wanted to like re-watch
it and
the like the more i watch it i'm glad i
watched hereditary a second time and i'm
glad i watched midsummer second time i'm
pretty sure
ari astor is a [ __ ] genius i'm pretty
sure
well i'll tell you what i didn't like i
didn't like uh what you called the first
hereditary the first time i saw it i
fell asleep in it the second time i saw
it i liked it better i still didn't like
it as much as a
as as midsummer and that's fair mid
midsummer's
to me a lot more of an understandable
linear story
hereditary is kind of like a puzzle you
really have to pay attention and you
have to wait for payoffs and stuff
and things happen in a certain order
it's not spelled out
if you're really not paying attention
because sometimes a mind will wander
i lost [ __ ] big set big sections of
the hereditary [ __ ] story in the plot
that you really got to pay attention to
i really got a page but mid-summer
it kind of pulls you in because it's a
lot more situational and the story is
being told in a linear fashion i mean
it's more straightforward real
straightforward
and it's kind of like it's it's
basically the same kind of concept as
uh wicker man yeah essentially
essentially it's wicker man
uh updated it's [ __ ] really cool who
whoever wrote
this really did their homework even with
their yesterday
yeah they wrote it and directed it yeah
and there's all kinds of [ __ ]
callbacks if you know
[ __ ] gothic neofolk music like death
in june
and [ __ ] like that that's in the music
is in there
because you know death and june current
93 david tibet
and all those guys douglas pierce
they were real big fans of [ __ ] uh
the wicker man
and they were big into damn
neo folk you're you [ __ ] basically
you're talking about [ __ ]
honky magic all right that's what it is
back in the motherland yeah this is like
white voodoo is what you were talking
about
back when white people were kind of like
kind of like aztecs cutting people's
hearts out upon temples it's [ __ ]
scary but they were doing this [ __ ] for
a reason
but the thing is is that killing
somebody will not make it rain but these
people think it will you know what i
mean and that's scary enough
i'm sure you know [ __ ] this is a cult
that [ __ ] kills people because they
think it's
it's going to help nature and [ __ ] force
right now says crazy swedes
yeah yeah swedish people doing this yeah
sleazy bees ask if it's on netflix i
believe it's on amazon prime
actually if you have an amazon prime
subscription i'm pretty sure you can
watch it for free
but we have it up we have the blu-ray
which is good because we have all the um
there's actually like a really nice
there's not a ton of special features on
it but there's like a good
like half an hour 40 minute uh making of
a documentary on it which i watched
which which i thought was really good i
really appreciated the score this time
a lot more than i did the first time
seeing it i was just hearing all these
damn
musical cues from those bands that i
just mentioned
he knows those bands or listen to this
music
and even he there's even a part where
one of the high priests shows up with
his face covered behind this thing looks
like a mop douglas pierce was wearing
one of those during one of his shows one
time
yeah i remember so yeah it's some kind
of a
druidic thing i don't know it's just
like perfect either that or
he just saw he just saw douglas pierce
wearing that he goes i'm gonna have that
dude with it
that's cool it might have been a mop
douglas pierce would have put a mop over
his face
that cut a piece of a mop out and have
that hanging it was something
i've seen that before though i'm pretty
sure that's like something that has some
say
yeah it's some kind of religious
significance you see he's not really
mop heads yeah they're not really
pulling this out of their ass
you know what i mean they're not really
making this up stuff like this did exist
in europe in the early 1900s there was a
big
neo pagan [ __ ] revival
in this all right the the damn german
nationalist socialist workers party you
know you know him as the [ __ ]
mustache man's nazis they were kinda
partially inspired by some of the weird
neo-paganism that was coming out of the
early 1900s in europe
it was uh just kind of like a
this it was in the in the us
it kind of manifested as people being
interested in seances
and spirit spiritism in europe it was
that but also kind of like
trying to go back to a pr to the
pre-christian era
they were trying to do that they were
bringing back norse runes and
symbols and uh and it was all about kind
of like the green movement too
it had to do with the cycles in nature
and
the thing is though man nature is not
like what you know
70s california hippies think it is
nature involves killing [ __ ]
all right things only live because they
kill other things
it's food you know everything imposes on
something else
even inanimate objects [ __ ] each other
over
by taking up space that another object
could occupy
you know grass is [ __ ] competing with
each other for sunlight
and nutrients you know there's you just
cannot live without imposing on other
things
and that's kind of like the essence of
that neo-paganism
and it's just it's kind of shown in this
too
but there's a bunch of magical thinking
involved also you know
setting bears on fire turning people
into bears and [ __ ]
group sex is kind of like just this damn
weird-ass ritual of getting some chick
pregnant
and they it it's just weird weird [ __ ]
but it makes sense when you kind of
think about it from a primitive mindset
well and the thing about it too the
thing that's great about this that i
picked up on the first time i've watched
it but this is definitely one just like
hereditary is where it gets better like
the more times you watch it
yeah because you pick up a lot more
stuff because i guess like ari aster
is like so he has like planned out
every single everything like every
single
shot every single detail every single
way the camera moves and it's like
everything that [ __ ] is going on in the
background
it's like he's really and like i saw
some interviews with like
people that have worked with him on the
movies and they say that too it's like
he everything is like totally totally
planned
and it's like everything means something
and
that's going on in this one too the
thing that i love about this
is that it's really much like the wicker
man it's really really hard
to make a creepy i don't know if i'd
call this movie so much
scary but it's very it's unsettling it's
a very unsettling movie
and the whole thing is daytime
there's one scene where um where danny
the main character um
where she's i think she's dreaming and
she comes out and it's night time but
that's a dream
because they're in you know they're
above like the arctic circle so the sun
doesn't ever really go down
yeah now the girl that plays annie
what's her name
uh danny danny what's her name lawrence
peale yeah she was also
played um in uh fighting with my family
yeah she's been in tons of [ __ ] yeah
she's awesome yeah she's cute she's real
cute in this
little bitty chick big head but kind of
a cute head
he can't say it like yeah she got i like
her head
she's like he's like i really dig her
she's got like a big head
yeah that's like like in a good way is
her head big though
well i don't it's either she had a big
head or she had like a square face and
with a real
strong defined jaw so it kind of made it
look bigger than it was yeah
she's kind of thin in this but she
played that one
uh wrestler a page she played page and
fighting with my family i recommend that
one also
that's also a very good move that was
such a good match
yeah that's another florida movie now
yeah up there with up there with uh
[ __ ] no oh no pain and gain yeah it's
like that
you know what i found okay so maybe
people that are in the uk would have
probably realized this i knew florence
pugh was british
um you know even though she plays an
american in this movie however
until i watched the documentary about
the making of
i didn't realize that the dude that
plays her boyfriend
christian is also british i think he's
irish
and the dude that plays mark the douchey
like
comic relief dude that dude is also
british yeah i don't think there were
any americans in this
uh no the one guy played that was
playing the um the dude the anthropology
student the black guy
yeah yeah like that guy was american
right but all the
everybody else was british or the dude
that played um pele was
actually swedish that's why the acting
was good i know
i didn't i didn't realize like i said i
knew florence p was british because i've
seen her in a bunch of other stuff
yeah but um i guess well like the two
other guys were in it i guess
like they've been in a bunch of british
movies like together because they said
well you know we knew each other
from previously so they had worked on
some movies before
but um so it's not only awesome that
they made this such a creepy [ __ ]
movie
yeah and it's completely daytime other
than like the beginning
like where danny's family dies but
um it's just
i like that the way the way they
juxtapose
the cult i guess you'd call them a cult
although cold yeah that is a cult
um the small religion yeah they the way
they juxtapose that
with like the sunlight but also the cult
don't really seem to be hiding much of
anything from them
you know what i mean like they're like
showing what they do what they do
like you know the old people like jump
off the cliff or whatever
yeah and that made sense to them though
it did
because at 72 you have to [ __ ] take
your own life
because you've lived a good life with
them they've been doing this [ __ ] for a
long time and then it's time for you to
be recycled it's time for you to be
recycled it's like it's like carousel
yeah
out of logan's run and you have to go
while you're still healthy and happy
because once you go beyond that once you
get beyond that time
you become miserable because you're
fighting death and you start to decline
too much
yeah you become a burden to yourself and
to others and you
and so these people all these people
this cult willingly face death
like it's no big deal yeah they
volunteer to be sacrificed which like i
said it's like it's scary because
a lot of the [ __ ] they say like makes
sense yeah yeah and they all seem to be
like happy and they're all nice and
stuff like that even though they kill
people like but they
but they're killing people not because
they hate them because they
want that one dude well yeah but that
one dude was a jackass yeah that one
[Laughter]
they uh they don't have any problems
with taking vengeance
and uh you know so if you [ __ ] them over
or try to steal from them
or try to disrespect them they
uh they punish you yeah because they
they're like well we needed to sacrifice
anyway and here you are baby
dick so and they're doing it they're
doing it in [ __ ] ways that were kind
of legendary for like vikings i'm not
gonna [ __ ] mention the punishments
but it's a lot of [ __ ] pre-christian
punishments that they do to people
you know i mean which which are in line
with
the motif of this coat and there's a lot
of creepy [ __ ] man they're little
swedish old-fashioned swedish houses and
buildings that they make
and they built that whole entire this
was actually not shot in sweden it was
shot in hungary
okay but um it looks like sweden yeah
but they but
he found this location he's like we
found this big [ __ ] field that looked
like
and they built that whole entire village
yeah like for the movie and on the walls
there's all these little folk drawings
and pictures that they put and all these
weird runes and stuff and the pictures
are [ __ ] disturbing
and you're like that's got to be an
allegory for something else
it is allegory but they're going to do
that yeah well
and honestly like when they show like
before the credits
like they show like a mural or something
like that everything in that mural
happens
yeah in the movie so it's almost kind of
like he's spoiling it like in the
beginning
yeah you were like that's a creepy
picture well you'll see that [ __ ] later
yeah yeah it's not in there for no
reason right that's
it's foreshadowing is what that is yeah
and this is take they're having this
festival they only have it once every 90
years it's a big
change of certain cycle and that's why
they've kind of like
brought these other people in i think
it's every 90 years they bring a person
yeah it's 90 years
but they also bring in new members in
other ways i think because those people
were brought in but then you find out
what what they mean by bringing in a new
member
that's got a different [ __ ] you
you join up but i ain't gonna [ __ ]
spoil it
you can't join them but not for long
[Laughter]
you'll see although yeah it's like it's
hard to talk about without spoiling it
but
well pat hatfield asks i've seen the
wicker man with christopher lee which is
a classic
and i heard that mid-summer was similar
so my question is is there a reason to
watch midsummer or is it just
interchangeable with the wicker man
it's not um it's not totally
interchangeable it's not it's
it's not the same story um thematically
it's kind of similar but basically with
the story of
uh midsummer or midsomar if you want to
pronounce it correctly
um what the story with that is is it's
almost like it's now it's long it's two
and a half hours and it's real
it goes by fast though yeah i didn't
find it slow but maybe some people would
i don't know it's real it's real trippy
and it takes like a while
um there's like a lot of build up to it
because it's not
just the story of these americans
that go to this swedish village because
one of them like i said is an
anthropology student he's gonna study
them and blah blah blah
and um so it's not they go there and
then
like creepy cult [ __ ] ensues like you
know it takes a while to get to that
point
but it's also a weird
kind of thing kind of much like
hereditary was kind of like a thing
about like grief and family trauma and
things like that
this is uh ari astr has called this like
a [ __ ] up
breakup movie which is exactly what it
is basically it's almost kind of like
florence pugh's character danny it's her
deteriorating relationship with her
boyfriend yeah and almost her becoming
empowered but in a really [ __ ] up
perverse way yeah yeah
here's something else if you watch the i
was watching and i was going that's
pretty [ __ ] up that's the horror
element of what happens
danny's not a role model she's not
[ __ ] mentally [ __ ] right
no you know she's [ __ ] up but um
but understandably so yeah she finds her
place with this [ __ ] cult eventually
in a way
so that's the that's the horror element
of the story
basically it's almost kind of like it's
a story about grief and breakups but
it's also about indoctrination
yeah in a way belief yeah
and it's almost kind of like because i
it's really weird because
i saw like an analysis of this that said
something about it really astute they
said
um from danny's point of view this movie
is like
a fairy tale it's like the wizard of oz
her finding her place
yeah from all the other characters point
of view it's a horror movie yeah
so it's like i thought that was like a
really good that's exactly like the
right way to look at it yeah
in the wicker man the the the meaning
behind the wicker man
is that no sacrificing people
does not make it rain okay but also
going around
and judging people by the christian
mindset
doesn't necessarily make people bad in
other words
that cop was going around sergeant howie
yeah he was going around kind of
condemning people for their beliefs as
if that made him
more morally superior when actually
they're both believing in [ __ ] that's
kind of [ __ ]
that was the music yeah i'm pretty sure
that was the whole theme of that movie
yeah
this movie is yeah it's [ __ ] but it
doesn't matter
it makes some people happy that's
[ __ ] i think the meaning of the movie
what this girl does ends up doing this
movie is [ __ ] but it didn't matter
to her it made her happy
everything was it was like subjective
everybody lives in like a subjective
reality and you could almost kind of see
it too as like
like i said it's really perverse and
[ __ ] up like what happens at the end
but she's so messed up that from her
point of view
it seems like a good thing like i said
it seems like empowering
because she's found a place her big
thing like
the reason um you know that her
relationship with her boyfriend whose
name is christian
um you know he's very emotionally
distant she feels like she always has to
like
hide her emotions from him because
they're like inconvenient for him and
like all these other kind of stuff
yeah that too and it's like he kind of
wants to break up with her but then he
feels kind of bad so he's like really
apathetic about it
and you know she has goes through this
horrible tragedy like at the beginning
of the movie and he's not really there
for her
he was gonna break up with her but and
he was gonna and then he felt bad
and then like and then they end up going
on this trip which he actually didn't
wasn't even gonna tell her about but
then like she accidentally found out
about it so she goes
he wasn't a bad guy it's just that he
was uh he wasn't putting her out of her
misery really
he didn't love her she should have broke
up with her a long time ago yeah and his
friends were saying that and the fact
that he couldn't
pull the trigger on yeah he was kind of
a coward yeah
and like i said but he was a real like
apathetic he wasn't like giving her
anything that she needed
and it's just kind of like you know and
she was messed up too it's like so it
was like his [ __ ] up like codependent
relationship well
if you did if you haven't noticed
basically all the
all the all the outsiders all the
the boys pretty much they go they're all
betas basically
the alphas were in the cult in certain
ways
yeah did you notice that remember the
dude remember the dude
i can't really [ __ ] want to break it
but the dude is pissed off about the
tree
yeah you know what i mean [ __ ] he
he stood up for what he believed in and
he pulled the trigger on what at least
one of them
yeah yeah i mean those these guys were
kind of like betas they were kind of
like you're
well they're supposed to be like a
representation like
like the guy that that pissed on the
tree was the fool
yeah um which they actually kind of uh
allude to like later on in the movie
like what happened
you see that happening when he's
tripping yeah in the beginning he's
going
this motherfucker's a loser it should
although he did make me laugh like a
bunch of times like when they were doing
the magic mushrooms
yeah and he's like what what time is it
and they're like it's 9 p.m and it's
still like daylight he's like i don't i
don't like that
he couldn't roll with anything but yeah
well and everything was like a joke to
him yeah he was like making fun of
everything it's like you know
somebody tell those girls they're
walking stupid or something like that
the the the the the meaning to me was
this [ __ ]
they were basically a bunch of they were
kind of represented the mainstream kind
of mundanes
and uh how kind of like fish out of
water they were when they're outside
their own element and they
kind of like they're dependent on a
certain societal system once they're out
of that they can't
they can't function well and then the
one guy that was going there to do his
thesis yeah was seemingly kind of
sympathetic but he was also
seeing the cult the horgas they were
called
kind of seeing them from an academic
yeah standpoint and he went around and
did [ __ ]
like they're like hey you can't take
pictures of our sacred book you can't do
this but then he would sneak around and
do it anyway
yeah the modern people in this so it was
disrespectful
the college kids in this are all
artificial people basically
the horga were more real people they
were
emotional based and it was more like
magical thinking and in a certain way
and
they believed in what they did they were
not commercial they weren't products of
the commercial world
they were more like primitive people
well they were also advanced at the same
time
that's how that's why danny ended up
kind of finding her place with them
because
they unlike her boyfriend and unlike
her boyfriend's friends the people she
was with they allowed her to feel the
way she was feeling and they
empathized yeah with her like they
there's these really weird scenes where
she's like have crying or having a panic
attack
and all the other women are like crying
with her you know what i mean until
they're they're all like
that's like what scientology is like
yeah like taking her pain on and things
like that but like i said there's
there's
a there's an element of indoctrination
too because they're essentially like
love bombing
yeah yeah if you understand scientology
you'll see a lot of
science a lot of psychology tactics and
that mirroring people emotionally to try
to try to get in with them love bombing
[ __ ] all that kind of [ __ ]
yeah fair fair gaming people yeah and
she was totally open for it because
you know the situation that she was in
yeah
so it's it's it's just as i said the
like
i think the one that we have on the
blu-ray that might be
the director's cut which i think is
longer than the one
that we saw in the theater i didn't
remember it being any different than the
one although i yeah that's what i was
thinking too because i was looking at
the wikipedia page and it was saying
yeah the one that's on blu-ray unless
that one was like limited
edition because this version was like
what two and a half hours long something
like that
but i can't remember how long it was
when we saw it in the theater i remember
it being long
but i didn't know if it was two and a
half hours maybe but then when we
watched it again there wasn't anything
in there that i didn't remember being in
there before but
my advice on this movie is if if you
liked hereditary you'd like this movie
even though they're very different
if you didn't like hereditary you'd like
this one better
like i didn't like hereditary that much
i like this one a lot better
it's interesting because kind of weird i
know it's a weird thing to say thank you
mr roboto
so would you and jenny survive
mid-summer
yeah probably yeah but they'd kill you
anyway probably
well they needed some sacrifice yeah
they did yeah they probably ended up
killing you
what happened i don't wouldn't have made
a lot of mistakes that they made
but they probably i don't think there
was any way out of there
probably not although
i'm not sure though because remember how
they were talking about
the horga and how they saw all of life
as
seasons right so it's like up until you
were 18 that was spring
and then from 18 to 36 i think it was
that was summer and that's when you went
on your pilgrimage
so you went out into the world and so
like when all of the
people that were going through the
summer when they brought people back to
the village
like for the festival um i don't think
they killed all those people
because there were some other ones i
think they killed a ball
no because they only needed nine i don't
think there were any witnesses
maybe not but they it's like i said they
only needed nine
and the whole thing about letting that
guy do his um
his thesis his thesis that was [ __ ]
they they intended to kill all those
people
probably they just told him not to keep
him quiet for the time being
because that's what it eventually ended
up happening pat said i like hereditary
so i'll watch this one yeah
it's like thematically um
it's kind of similar which is a weird
thing cult yeah
but um but it's a totally different
whereas hereditary was just like very
dark very yeah
this one is like super brightly lit and
it's like beautiful to look at it's like
there's flowers
and it's like there's all this like
trippy [ __ ] in the background like
the trees are swirling and [ __ ] yeah
they're on hallucinogenics a lot of
times and you're kind of seeing things
how they see it they're
[ __ ] tripping out the background the
[ __ ] force start pulsating in the
back because they're all [ __ ] high
weird [ __ ] happens in it
yeah it's yeah it's cool and it's like
and even though it's bright it's
happening outside
you know bad shit's gonna happen and it
kind of makes it worse
and they'll show you some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and it's in the middle of the day you're
like whoa
you know yeah
there's one part in this it's that's
that i felt was kind of like the
equivalent of
you know the the uh smash cut to
charlie's head in
hereditary yeah there's a scene where
because it this movie takes
a while i mean there's [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happens at the beginning like before
they even get to sweden like with uh
danny's family and everything so it's
like this big tragedy
and then once they get over there and
everything's like bright and gorgeous
and flowery and everything
and then so it goes on like that for a
while and for a while you're kind of
thinking oh these seem like nice happy
people like they're a little weird but
you know what i mean they just
you know they're all like hippies and
everything and um
but then there comes a point where
there's there's a ritual and they're all
just like standing there and you're like
and it's pretty [ __ ] up it's like
pretty gruesome yeah
and everyone's just totally chill about
it yeah they had their own explanation
for it
it was the same kind of things you'd see
down the capital city of [ __ ]
the aztec empire that kind of stuff
human sacrifice they were cool with it
you know and they were cool with
cannibalism in mexico during that time
you didn't waste that meat you know that
was part of the sacrifice so it was kind
of
like that and it's just normalized
but outsiders are tripping you know like
wow you know
no they're screaming what's wrong with
you people they're like no what's wrong
with you
you know yeah they're like it's funny
yeah yeah they're
they are happy people yeah it's not fake
no they're happy people they're they're
i guess you could say they're good
people
but they don't really see you as a good
person if you're an outsider
and kind of from their point of view for
their belief system you aren't a good
person to them
so they can do [ __ ] up [ __ ] to you and
they feel good about it
you know yeah it's just part of belief
well that's just uh what the world is we
gotta do every now and then yeah that's
kind of the way the world is
well like i said i think they do it
every 90 years they said right so yeah
but i think there was other [ __ ] they
were doing on a pretty regular basis
though
yeah probably you know it's just they
don't talk about that yeah
it's yeah it's just
i'm glad that we watched it again
because
i liked it so much better like i liked
it a lot the first time
i probably still like hereditary a
little bit better but i don't know
they're but they're both different so
it's like hard to compare
this one's a lot easier to understand
yeah i mean this one is not
because like you said the thing that you
didn't like about hereditary so much was
that you really really had to pay
attention because everything was like a
puzzle it was like interconnected and
you missed like large chunks of plot
because you weren't really paying
attention yeah or i just didn't notice
what it was they were trying to show us
this one is kind of more like a
straightforward story because it's like
these people that you know they go
to sweden and then there's this cult and
there's nefarious [ __ ] going on
um and that's like pretty easy to
understand
so but that said
if you go back and watch it again
um like i said there you'll notice like
all this [ __ ]
like you know the murals that were in
the background that like basically tell
you what's gonna happen
um there was one point where
i can't remember like what scene it was
it was one scene i think it was when
uh they were carrying like the may queen
and um
in the background of the trees was
danny's sister's face like kind of
superimposed like over the trees
real trippy but it's like yeah so
there's notice that yeah there's there's
points
so it's like all kind of like crazy [ __ ]
going on in the background like that
like i said
a lot of times because they use a lot of
hallucinogens um you know like magic
mushrooms and like hallucinogenic teas
and stuff
and whenever people are on that um you
know the
the background starts undulating yeah
and um you know people flowers are
moving the flowers are kind of moving on
people's like and and people's faces
are kind of distorting but just slightly
yeah um so it's like really really
it's it's really unsettling the food
looks like it's breathing it doesn't
look like that and it's like really
[ __ ] weird
but it's like subtle you know what i
mean it's not like super epic she had to
push it she had to point some of it out
yeah i didn't see it i wasn't seeing it
all the time yeah
but it's good it's like you know what i
mean if like i said if you like folk or
at all if you like the wicker man
it's along those lines but it's like a
totally different
story i mean yeah it's like a cult and
it's similar but it's not really
the same story yeah and there's a lot of
other [ __ ] going on in there too
everybody's talking yeah a pretty cool
comment again yeah
drug cartels have a right to me
[Music]
mark kilroy somebody said we should do a
podcast on that case
i'll write it down i think i know
the case that you're talking about but
i'll check and see
yeah but uh no i think there's a good
movie like i said
if you liked hereditary you'd like this
one if you didn't like hereditary you'd
like this one
because a lot of reasons why i think a
lot of people wouldn't like hereditary
just how complicated that story is
this one's a lot easier to understand
it's a really in your face
but it has that [ __ ] same creepiness
it just comes at you in a different way
yeah and it's really and and the groot
the gruesome
[ __ ] that happens i think is all the
more effective
because it goes on for so long without
anything
necessarily seeming like it's the matter
now we saw this in the theater
and there was a couple of uh a couple of
normies you know
watching it with us and when it was over
they were just like because they were
kind of like the kind of people that
would have been [ __ ] killed by the
horde
[Laughter]
but it is weird if you it is cool if you
know what
you're seeing you know i mean i don't
think those people knew what it was that
they were seeing there huh what
just like that it's a pretty weird
aspect there's no explosions in that
it's a weird ass movie yeah it's weird
and it's long and you really have to
like i said you really have to get
into it and you have to like kind of get
because because it takes a while for
like
right just like a person who's never
even heard of the wicker man movie
or never you know what i mean then you
probably wouldn't know what kind of
movie this was
yeah you know you don't have to see the
wicker band to see it
but yeah you'll still get it but but you
know if you didn't even know a movie
like that existed you probably wouldn't
get it and you know it's it's not really
a horror movie for normies
yeah it's kind of a [ __ ] and honestly
too
yeah and i think a lot of the horror is
not
it's not normal real overt right you
have to think about it
yeah it's more it's it's more horror by
implication
i mean there is like some gr really
gruesome [ __ ] that happens in this
yeah but um that's not necessarily where
the horror comes from
and most of that doesn't happen until
like toward the end yeah the horror is
kind of like the distortion of morality
and feelings of what it'd be like to be
an outsider in a real
you're an outsider and you're around
this cult and they have
an alien moral system that you don't
really fully understand
and they're kind of a threat but they
don't really seem like it yeah they're
friendly
and they all they're all good-looking
too they don't really have any ugly
people there's one person who's ugly and
it was on purpose
yeah ugly on purpose
[Laughter]
he was bred to be ugly he's the oracle
yeah
they are so it's weird yeah it's a weird
ass flick but yeah if you like folk
horror then
you should definitely watch it and i'm
like i said i'm glad we watched it a
second time and uh
i'm dying to see what ari astr's next
movie is going to be because like i said
i'm pretty sure that dude's legit a
genius
i think somebody told me that he had
made a short film
before hereditary came out and what's it
called i think it's called the strange
thing about the johnsons or something
like that and somebody told me i needed
to watch that because it was like kick
ass
so i think he made a couple short films
before he made hereditary but hereditary
was like
his first feature length and when i was
watching the um
the extras like on midsummer he said
basically
he went to the premiere of hereditary
like the summer of 2018 and the next day
they went to hungary and started
shooting this one but this
they showed like they built like the
whole [ __ ] village so all that stuff
you see there is actually really there
they built all of it um exactly to his
specifications
and uh yeah it looks [ __ ] great
so mr roboto so they would have been
better as a walrus
yeah they'd have been better yeah they'd
have been better as a wallet
wouldn't we all yeah that's that's a
[ __ ] good movie too it's weird
i love weird movies man i just really do
because you guys haven't seen tusk see
tusk
that's the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
pat says dear god stay away from that
short film oh now i'm intrigued
why because it's bad or because it's
like really scary i don't really know
i'm sure it was like really awesome all
right so you ready to like wrap it up
because
yeah we got some we got some food
cooking in the oven
and make some spanish chicken and some
rice and beans yeah it'll be really good
yeah so uh we'll probably watch a movie
this evening
and uh be back tomorrow for another
matinee
so have a good rest of your weekend you
guys thank somebody for dropping by
thanks for super chats and all of that
jazz
and uh we'll see you guys tomorrow
afternoon bye